Now, let's breakdown our monolith
application into micro services.
Ideally we want to break our
monolith around functionality
that's self-contained.
So I create an auth and hello service.
Each service has its own binary.
Let's build and run both of them now and
see what it's like to work with
the new application deployment.
I'm going to start
with the hello service.
In a new shell tab,
I'll do the same for the auth service.
Now that I have both services running,
I can use the curl command
in a new shell to interact with
the auth and hello micro services.
Now that we have multiple
binaries to manage for
our application, our deployment has
been made twice as complex, and
now our clients need to know how
to talk to two separate services.
The additional complexity only
grows as the number of services for
an application increases.
This problem is exactly what's driving
the adoption of application containers
and management platforms,
like curbernetties, to coordinate them.